welcome to this video or play it unless
your masters oh she from Egypt and this
is a very high rated for 15 minutes so
we have a clash offer top-rated players
at least for like being online there are
some players rated higher than that in
15 minute but not many ok we have um a
double fianchetto which is a been
opening that I've played often but
haven't studied for a while so I tend to
forget things the idea is to make it ok
he goes for a goon felt setup normally
were very often black plays d6 for Kings
Indian then why place d for two to make
sure that if I've is not easily played
ok let's see him he is taken very
quickly on c4 this is some setup that
and you've never really liked for black
due to the most 95 I only wonder is this
the exact position I think it is he
cannot really pin me the night only five
is a bit reliable and this not
understand now if he moves the night but
I can take on c6 with the tempo on the
Queen so this is a bit different if the
Queen has has moved what I want to do is
I want to exchange the Knights here of
course takes Bishop takes and then the
bishop on g2 is very strong on this long
diagonal it always puts pressure on the
queenside and very often you get to a
position I mean let's sir just wait
until he captures the seems almost
forced
other than that I'm taking into six okay
can you move the night somewhere like
Knight a5 this looks a really strange
aha to default interesting
and very interesting choice maybe ah
maybe not so bad hmm
yeah now the night on e5 is not
protected and might be might be attacked
soon
I can play III just kicking it but right
is 6 I guess they are not sure that this
really is a great setup for black I'm
going to do that he cannot really play
counter attack on the hive night as I
take with the poor Ned cover it so
there's no 98 or something I take just
take the night with the pond and I
really only see night yeah okay to f5 to
f5 ok so the still means that there are
maybe ideas like moving the snide and
utilizing the pin so i probably I
probably should protect the bishop it's
at least a useful move I wonder maybe
queen bee three here yeah this looks ok
protecting b2 and term putting some
pressure on b7 it prevents a move like
rugby aid because of knight c6 we're
just when they exchange
and what I'm not sure about is what to
do with the be one night I don't really
want to play Knight c3 and and put it in
the way of the b2b shop d 392 as
possible but the night is not doing much
there yes this is what I actually
expected so that the b7 poorness is
protected for the moment let's let's see
you will probably play butcher p6 Sam
soon ok I'm to do that after all keeping
c4 guarded and preparing 92 and I'm not
really sure about this nightly tool
that's not a good move really hmm maybe
I don't really need to move it yet I can
also first play stuff like a 4 a 5 which
would fit very well into the the general
plan if you place Bishop e6 then just a
form ok he's got an entirely different
idea okay well I need to take anyway no
need to waste time ok so what now should
I am take on g7 first or
yeah don't think that is a reason not to
ok he's not threatening Bishop b2
because of Queen B to check this is a
very important detail I wonder if Queen
d7 Bishop h3s something I should take
care of
hmm jam Knight c3 queen d 7 I'm bishop
remove the rock on everyone i can play
Bishop h1 on bishop age three I don't
really want to trade this the bishop on
g2 s my my best piece really
okay let's let's play this first if he
goes 27 I will probably just move the
rock not not sure where I really look
there maybe even to be one there's also
Queen a three possible attacking c5 that
the moment he cannot reply be 60 maybe
needs to move a look even
you have the only issue is my pawn on d3
can be this can be weakness really
campus at age three
hmm
jam that's it's really a lot so easy
what is the the way to go here I'm
wondering also bot night beehive maybe
maybe this is an idea to immediately
threaten to to grab stuff on d6 and d7
if it takes Queen takes Queen d3 Quincy
five hm that's not really clear takes
Queen takes Queen takes e-beam this is
hanging at the Roxy one but that's also
probably not better in this position
yeah I'm not sure I don't want to trade
the bishop ESL playbook be one first but
in general I think I should exchange
nights with 95 or on 94 the night on d6
is simply always protecting b7 and this
is this is a problem if you place a move
like here I cannot play that same night
f5 button p7s just just hanging I what I
wanted to say is i also have 94 then 95
is also a move that i should consider
just for the fact that he cannot really
reporter he has problems to reply with
e6 due to this check on c300 be too yeah
one issue here is not really threatening
anything it's a nice but it's not like
I'm I'm threatening much maybe 90 for
attacking c5 and unmasking against b7
what you always can do is play something
like rugby aid and then possibly be six
but okay I have a4 a5 as a as a possible
reply
yeah I'm not so sure if I'm having a
small advantage here if like a pin has
equalized with some precise moves
probably the latter yeah has liquid Isis
maybe maybe it'd be too much but he he
can certainly I think that he should
certainly should be able to to to defend
without too much of a problem him
nobody's taking some time maybe has
entirely entirely different idea that
I'm absolutely not the way off i can not
sure
yeah I don't know maybe crazy move f5
but that's not really working due to 95
f5 intending f4 EF look at for GM for
Queen g4 yeah this is I was briefly
thinking about and thought this is one
of those completely enter positional
moves that no one is going to play but
he just he just played it it really
looks very strange what is it doing
besides weakening d5 horribly okay so
let's um let's check this it really
looks terrible but maybe it is some it
is better than its first appearance if I
play Knight to g5 I'm not getting
anywhere probably it looks nice but what
it what exactly is it doing I'm actually
thinking about 94 getting getting this
exchanged knight takes Bishop takes and
then there's the porn hanging on b7 and
I have the possibility to put the bishop
on d5 hmm that's that's not bad no for
starters that's not bad taking on b7 is
ridiculous after Luke p8 so this is not
not really on might be five you can take
with me some player also shouldn't do
that so really Knightly form or maybe
yeah I really don't like you five but
maybe there's no direct way to refute it
it's possible it's 94 right I don't know
come on I'm spending lots of time here
in the mail at the end I'm going to play
it anyway so let's do that he needs to
exchange anyway I guess and then look be
eight so now Bishop here I want to get
out of out of the temple and also be
able to play Quincy three
ok
it has a five year okay it's still the
right to go play Quincy 3 after that if
I this almost forced now I think unless
he wants to use this idea of b5 like a5
b5 this might be possible if you place
them in flag rock the aid but I look the
ADA play Quincy three play Queen c3
first of course it's still he's got this
Bishop on a dream this is of course
something to be concerned about Queen on
g2 would be most unpleasant I even must
be must be aware of sacrifices on d5
let's say just roughly like Queen g4
look the eight takes on d5 takes Queen
f3 Queen g2 made this kind of idea so if
he gets pieces near the king I better be
better be cautious I have lots of stuff
on the a and B far so it's not like I'm
defending the king with our forces but I
have some some useful moves yeah this
was a possibility i thought this Prince
III would be quite good at first
to get you five on that check and make
it difficult for him to play a form so
if it covers it like with Queenie seven
for example after f4i just take so a
five is the logical move now there is
also a form but I'm not sure that I want
to do that a form hmm maybe this is
strong maybe by the way is he going with
the King out of this to h6 maybe okay
whatever I'm going to play a five
opening up the a file it's also very
important in terms of counter play so
ruga a7 gets them into the game
yeah i think this strategically very
nice for white but still needs to be
played with caution yeah okay this I can
do first so now let's see we have Brooke
a success the materialistic approach for
if he goes f4i take take I have rook you
one also getting on the e-file
yeah I don't know look asics it's not
not so easy to play for him he probably
will play a phone ef ef does even Queen
d4 yeah I'm not so sure about all this
I'm not so sure if I if I can simply win
the basic spawn I would like to get on
the seventh ring of course bouquet 600 k
1 rho k 7 but this takes quite a number
of moves
I probably still said I should do it i
mean down to four minutes yeah now
that's what's clear but I don't want I
don't want to I don't want to let him
check this is worse of course now the
question is now rookie one may be
getting the e-file ok this is this draws
away from the b6 from the b6 square but
maybe I should still take why not take
really i'm covering most of that takes
takes there's no no direct threat and i
have Queen d2 queen e to he has maybe
after the capture I should to give the
check first and then take yeah this is
better yeah this is always always Harry
this counter play at the end
I can play he can play queenie queenie
to you can play Queenie to before taking
no no don't tell me that this is losing
out right I need to take anyway ah
really ok I just need to play a bit more
cautious and he's just toast in this
game it's not even difficult I can just
not taking on b6 and blackest this is
just a roux in this position yeah how do
I protect this now probably i don't ya
just only thought of capturing first ah
yeah Queen f1 mate and look here he's
playing the caption and f2 is exposed
okay with a Quincy one yeah I can play
Quincy one ok at least I saw this one
and that means that I'm not not lost at
least Wow
ok we'll cook eh I can take a form
yeah maybe this is still ok maybe
but how do i get a i'm not even i'm not
sure what he is playing now very hard
way maybe it just takes 2-3 i would
consider that just take it what am i
doing then ok someone active now he's
threatening to take yeah ok so i can go
can i play would be to look to Queen d3
Thanks no yeah I have half the time so
let's see i want to i wanted to use the
rook to cover kara have to i think he
needs to take d3 now or at least this
looks like the logical move to intending
look a queen d1 check possibly i'm not
quite sure where he is going
unfortunately this is not with an
increment so it might be tempting for
him to play on time we can take on g3
now rook d3 takes on f2 checking edge 1
f1 queen and mating so if he takes I
just recapture so this is not a problem
I can enter that as a pre move to shock
him ok what's now rook be too it's not
really helping Queen to Queen d1 to
trade for for safety check yeah come on
let's do that maybe I have something
better but
the same seems relatively easy to play
I could have taken with check first this
was this was very stupid he was just
giving it away okay but he cannot cover
the porn after the capture so it doesn't
matter okay check
check so I'm I had to pawn up now but
still a bit a bit down on time check
check check check check no black
resigned John tough game wow that was
that was a real shocker that I
overlooked Queenie to without the trade
I mean I really think black is
completely completely outplayed yet he
only has this kind of last-ditch counter
play that I just need to be cautious
about but it's nothing that that should
secure them the draw so he went here
took andrew k 6 f 4 so the computer
gives white 1.5 so it just a matter of
something challenge you know really
later okay so i took this is yeah maybe
this is questionable maybe this is
question all i was i well I didn't want
to have the capture on e3 and Queen g5
coming it's interesting to note that the
computer wants to play f3 uhm absolutely
never considered and I don't understand
that even what is the exact point okay
yeah okay the one point is that taking
is not really really helping this I
understand this is not really giving him
anything I meet I'm even threatening
this stuff yeah the computer is
merciless in this position it just it
just calculates every counter attack and
it diffuses it and with perfect defense
white is completely winning that that's
clear but I was I was far from perfect
and now I took this year I simply I
didn't see it Queenie to I mean I only
was thinking about that and then i give
this intermediate check and just have a
very comfortable position I mean he
needs to do something about the check
cannot even go here candy cane but
there's this additional idea not at the
moment but because of this but he has to
do a silly move like Queen g5 and not
silly but I mean an unwanted moocher and
then I'm just the porn up and this is a
target so it should win quite easily and
this really shocked me at first I
thought I'm completely lost at least
then I found this one which is strictly
the only move is threatening Nautilus
this mate and the capture and now he
played this one which is really a bit
shocking okay look be seven wins now
okay and this is probably not bad yeah
this is a tectum what is the big
difference look T to let just like we
played in the game this move and what
then I will plant new look t5 and looked
III wow that's really really a bit in
human unhuman unhuman I played this one
Chad I was glad to just just get the
Queen's off so that I'm not mated this
is not the best move i'm pretty sure but
i just was too scared at this moment
rookie to is the computer such as
suggestions still with a substantial
advantage attending this intending this
and i would I was too scared
just jumped to get the Queen's off and
voice I think just blundering this
basically we should have three years of
course easier but ok this this is also
and also possible check ya know we had
this position I don't really know if
there are some mr. if there are some
winning chances yeah
yeah black is really active with the
rook on the seventh and the computer
gives white more than one pawn but I am
I don't really I don't buy that his
movers f3 and then later f4 and this is
no winning try I don't believe it I
don't really see where how i get is this
rook out of my back as even the idea if
he gets to see 42 to counter-attack here
and if you get c 4 45 we have everything
on one flank and it's a draw and it
probably should be a draw but okay we
both had little time and chat and
continue to him I didn't make any
progress the rukon f-4s at your place
check but you can't just just blundered
the rook here it's probably a draw I
have no way to yeah it's really adds
that draw even I have no way to move the
rock no square and the King only five
means that i cannot play g4 so it's
completely dead okay that was a tough
game thanks for watching